President Biden is so absent from the
campaign Trail and from his own mind
that the Democrats are starting to mock
him calling him Bigfoot the big eyes top
Dem Challenger launching this PO
political ad that pokes fun at the
president for ducking the Democratic
primary race I thought I was good at
hiding so I asked around have you seen
Joe I mean how can you have tens of
thousands of people looking for you all
the time and not one person finds you I
looked for him everywhere even the
Democratic primary debate no
Joe and while the White House keeps
Biden locked up in the cellar the White
House is now banking on kamla to be able
to put more than two words together the
beep sharing her Deep Thoughts with the
ladies of the view what are you going to
do to stop the crazies I am scared as
heck we should all be scared yeah but as
we know and certainly this is a a table
of very powerful women we don't don't
run away from something when we're
scared we fight back against it that's
right right we' done a lot of good work
we need to let people know who BR it to
them there's a split screen that you can
throw up and
see and it's going to be the choice
between what is about respecting our
democracy what is about competence
versus
chaos Dana interesting so Biden gets
compared to Bigfoot and klet gets to see
Bigfoot up close at the
really I didn't see I couldn't I
could I couldn't see Bigfoot I couldn't
see it um a couple of things the new
there's another yet again a kamla Harris
makeover and she's going to come out and
she's going to have a new full court
press they decided to go with the ABC
contingent they got to spend a whole day
with her yesterday and they got the she
got the full treatment online the
podcast the Nightly News and uh of
course the view I hated that she said
I'm scared to death mhm you're the vice
president of the United States say I'm
scared we're going to win it's going to
be fine like where's the confidence and
then she tries to back that off then she
talks about chaos what's interesting is
that in Iowa and I know they don't care
about these people but in Iowa 35% of
the Republicans who voted said they're
they want disruption in the country so
they're not looking for the stability
that the Biden Administration says that
they can continue on for another eight
years and last point on Dean Phillips
the guy who's running against Biden it
this creates an interesting pain point
for Biden a little bit in New Hampshire
because Biden's name is not on the
ballot Dean Phillips name is on the
ballot and many other Democrats are
running in that primary and Biden is
nowhere to be found you can write his
name in and they're trying to do that
they have to spend like 4 million I
think to try to get people to write in
Biden's name on this ballot it doesn't
it doesn't exude confidence not at all
Harold do you know why he's called
Bigfoot I do not he's got big feet you
know uh what do you think of Dean
Phillips anyway I love his
screwdrivers look I I think if you're
going to run against somebody uh in a
primary and especially especially he
especially the president of your own
party um I wouldn't be running
commercials with Bigfoot I I'd be I'd be
uh contrasting myself with him what I'd
be doing differently or whatever the
issue might be I think it's funny but I
think you got to be serious if you're
running you run for for a lesser office
maybe you get a chuckle but if you're
going to run for the president in your
own party you got to do that now um if I
were the president I'd go to New
Hampshire uh and I I I'd campaign for a
day or so and make clear to Democrats
there what what's at stake two or three
with comma Harris it amazes me and
Dana's talked about this before you
can't get the three or four bullet
points down I mean you have to be able
to say our campaign is going to be about
touting how we've invested more in
America's ability to build Innovative
things from medicines to chips to cars
to ensuring that America's a leader too
we're going to make it where every every
woman and doctor doesn't have to fear
healthc care choices and talking about
them we're going to make sure uh that we
cut taxes for those earning on the
forign you these are the basic things I
don't know how how you're not able to
articulate and ramp off these points one
by one by one by one and then talk about
this the other stuff as I've said we
said in uh Iowa when you talk about
threats to democracy it cuts both ways
Republicans think evence you're saying
you're attacking Donald Trump and
Democrats think of it as saying you
should attack Donald Trump so this is
not this is not on the level kind of
number here so I think the economy and
border security will continue to be the
foremost issues on voters minds and if
the White House and the president and
Congress are able to address those
issues and not only will help the
country but it will help the party help
him help his party uh in the process and
I think even help Republicans as well
judge Dean Phillips KLA you
pick well I agree with Dana I think um I
think that kamla maybe she's had some
media training there's something
different about her now but what what
amazes me is she's she she's kind of
like Jill when Jill says he's got more
energy than anybody I know she says Joe
Biden can see around corners really
could he see around the corners with the
baby formula disaster could he see
around the corner with Afghanistan could
he see around the corner with the uh
with the classified documents that he
had for 20 years that he wasn't even
supposed to take out of this Giff I mean
and and the whole idea that she's scared
and she says quote we should all be
scared she's the vice president of the
United States she should be saying you
know we are we we've got your back we've
got you this is America the Biden
Administration is working for you
instead I mean they just watch your
numbers go lower and lower and you know
what he's got 18% on the on immigration
and now he wants to deal with it now the
nine months before the election now they
want to deal with it we had the biggest
month in history last month I mean
Americans all over consider themselves
part of a border state when they're not
and then she says the media is against
us are you kidding the media is carrying
their water the media is carrying their
stories we just did it in the last block
they won't even correct it when they get
something wrong and finally uh this idea
that she says the Republicans have
nothing to run against Joe Biden except
his age well 74% of Americans think he
shouldn't run because of his age so
nothing she says is saving or helping
them Jesse what have you to say about
this topic I think the Biden campaign's
getting a
facelift and I think kamla might be the
new face of the campaign Biden probably
is going to let Obama take the reign of
the campaign and it's because he's shot
he can't walk he can't talk he can't
campaign every time he goes out there he
fake jogs he does events they call them
and he doesn't even deliver a speech and
then he disappears for a few days and
then he pops up and screams democracy
and then just go back to Delaware and
hides I'm kicking myself I didn't think
of the Bigfoot analogy that is a sticky
analogy an honest press would gobble
that up and run with it these people
make their living on on content on
conflict on Buzz and and the Bigfoot
thing it's it's beautiful I was going to
say the White House is like the Bermuda
Triangle Joe goes near it and doesn't
see him for a week but again these are
the kind of things that if you were
covering a campaign you'd put right out
there but they're covering up a campaign
and that's why it's a sin hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else